this morning in the brainstorming
session one of the quotes on one of the
recommendations was the future is
embedded in the present and I think
that's perhaps a key to the unintended
or unexpected outcomes ten years ago
there were perhaps five or ten
universities internationally that had a
real pocket of expertise in statistical
NLP now almost every university has a
permanent every large University has a
permanent position in their computer
science staff working on statistical mt
presuming presumably incubating lots and
lots of expertise in this area what is
going to be the impact on this field
both research and the industry of this
outpouring of talent if you even agree
with the premise that there is going to
be an incubating pool of talent that we
haven't really had before in the past
ten years my observation that there is
somewhat of a divergence between what's
going on in Europe and what's going on
in the United States there's a lot of
funding for academic research and mt in
Europe there is more restricted funding
I would say or more concentrated funding
here in the United States that isn't
particularly going to academia and i
think that there's a lot that there's
also a lot of momentum of a lot of the
machine translation research is shifting
more towards industrial types of
settings and in some sense so i don't
know i think that there there will be
sort of progress coming out of academia
in nmt and certainly in NLP in general
will be a lot of progress coming in from
academia and specifically an mt I don't
know if there's going to be more coming
from academia or more coming from novel
things that are sort of more in
industrial space my two cents worth was
rather than just focus on the technology
having the biggest impact I think will
be the number of people that we've
actually trained up in our in our
environments who can be of use to you in
in companies so I just had
brain dump their some of my students are
now working for autodesk baidu Adobe
Microsoft Google semantic dot dot so the
number of students and postdocs that
we've trained up who can then go into
the industry and be of real use in you
know installing software not making it
work making it work better that pool of
people is growing but i also don't
necessarily agree with the initial
premise that you know many of these
people are isolated there are not large
group though there are very few large mt
groups in academia very few you know i
don't need all the fingers on both hands
to do that you're right there are
islands of of expertise but you know
people typically are operating in a
vacuum you know they are operating well
you know with with no local support I
agree with then the big problem in
academia is that very very few academic
environments have the resources required
to do real statistical machine
translation research nowadays so that
pushes automatically I think most of
interesting research occurring today's
in industrial environments in addition
to that I think the academic community
is extremely focused on a set of
problems that they know about okay so if
you start the ph.d program now there is
a natural language very likely you're
going to work on a better parser or to
improve a little bit the blue score of a
statistical machine translation if
you're lucky and the academic
environments are not at all exposed to
the wide set of problems that you've
seen even today in the last 30 minutes
and students there for PhD students they
don't start working on those programs
problems they don't imagine that's a
cool topic to work on so I'm not at all
optimistic with the respect to the how
successful your premise is going to turn
out into reality so if i may just add to
that because i was going to say the same
thing as andy i mean part of the output
of the CN jail program is not just on
the research but on a human
capital and we've seen the first crop of
students go out into industry what we're
finding now in fact is that there's so
much demand for graduates and students
going out into industry we're now trying
to recruit to fill that vacuum or
actually having extremely hard time
recruiting all the way from Professor
level to senior research fellows down
postdoctoral researchers there is a
limited supply for people coming in to
be a next wave of people trained up to
graduate and go out into the industry in
the response I think Alana I think it
was what I'm not sure if it was you or
Daniel but when one of you said
something about that sounded the gist of
it was like it's more incremental
improvements you know smaller advances
on unknown concepts and I that was
Declan when you were talking about your
list there that you finished up on that
was my one of my impressions from that
was all these are things we know we know
already I mean familiar topics that and
the incremental improvements are
valuable to and important and I guess
above all commercial I zabal but i was
thinking back to you know something
maybe a little bit more different and
new and what i was thinking of was adam
green that ubiquitous computing if i
forget what book he was that it was low
kworld and berlin a couple years ago and
i was wondering if any of you and your
researcher thinking are are exploring
that idea of what happens to language
computing and processing when computers
are ubiquitous in the way that Adam
Green was talking about some of you were
there so you remember his speech I
wasn't there but i'm usually maj ination
i'm much more optimistic on that topic
look the eye when i purchased my iphone
for a year ago or so and i looked at the
manual which was about five pages or one
sheet of paper that is smaller than this
ok and i read all the things that the
phone could do I was just blown away and
I remember telling my wife that if I
shown you this manual seven years ago
and I would have told you
in seven years you could get a device
that does all these things you would
have told me that I'm completely crazy
and that I'm living on a different
planet so I think the pace of change is
not the iphone the androids are equally
good and phones that Microsoft you know
that they're good to the that the point
is I think there is so much innovation
that is happening every single day right
and what is happening at a pace that we
don't even recognize it anymore and the
progress is incremental and every single
day in my life when I look at what
happened last week I'm extremely
disappointed because I feel that okay to
the last week nothing really happened
but we're nothing really of importance
but then I'm a date afraid so when I go
to my dashboards and I looked at what
happened in the last three months and
then I go and meet with my colleagues
and say look what happened in the last
three months and it's amazing oh my god
we've done so much in three months so i
think it's just we are accustomed so
much to very rapid change nowadays that
we don't appreciate it even more and
anymore so i think all is good don't
worry